Wow you guys are super early okay let's
talk about the house of X all right
let's talk about house with X in and
more in McTaggart all right
I like okay here's the thing aside from
when I first read the x-men I've never
really been confused by it there's
literally been an instance where I said
and I was like I don't know what's going
on here and I thought I had what Hickman
was doing sorted out do I do I not like
am I wrong
because from from my understanding with
house of X the the White House of X
played out especially like with more of
a Taggert is she dies and she's reborn
but she's not reborn as the same person
right she's not reborn with the same
experiences and all that kind of stuff
like she's just reborn as a person um I
mean maybe it is like Tom Cruise's edge
of tomorrow right we're like she dies
and she's reborn and it's basically I
mean I know this remembers everything
from before but she's reborn the exact
same person over and over and over again
every single time she dies but she
always remembers uh-hmm
okay well maybe I got that wrong because
I don't think that was the case like I
didn't think that was the case what's up
Kendal Taylor Rob Ford for life the only
reason I just want to make sure that I
have it right so I can correct it in the
next video but um what's going on Wow
everybody's showing up now huge clouds
yeah hey you guys want to see something
cool check this out maybe there we go
that's my eye productivity set up now
it's pretty cool I need to do a setup
video on it um okay yes let's talk about
this uh because I'm hmm okay somebody
it's like somebody tell me it's gonna be
kind of weird there's gonna be a weird
thing to do give me your perspective on
more on character from house of X is it
like edge of tomorrow if it was like
there tomorrow that'd make it a whole
lot simpler
thanks dude
I will yeah house of X is really awesome
here's Avengers from 2013 is in the same
she crazy new timeline every time she
dies that much I get she's in a
Groundhog Day loop see I didn't see I
didn't think that was the case every
time she dies
she comes back because but she comes
like she comes back herself like I said
it's a separate life for her right I
mean like like the family she was born
into all that kind of stuff is different
but the but everybody's I've always
remained the same like she always runs
him to Charles Xavier she always ends up
like eventually she falls in love with
Charles David but Xavier is always part
of the picture right like she always
comes across that circumstance where she
where she goes on and eventually like
encounters him and meets him right like
how she how she reacts with him is
different in every video but I'm sorry
different in every and every timeline
but I thought that she'd been through 11
like the current one is the 11th
timeline like the one where she died and
then like the current one the one where
she died when she was 13 when she was a
little kid and the current one is the
11th timeline huh the exact same family
all that kind of stuff okay well I guess
I need to fix that then because I don't
think it was Ed of tomorrow like I don't
think was an edit Amaro storyline see
that's what I'm wondering now alternate
universe scenarios because if if she's
born in she's 13 and then she dies of
the flu or whatever it is she dies of
like the fever
whatever was then and then she's
reincarnated then there's a reality
where that goes on without her in it and
then in the second universe if she if
she goes forward she creates secure and
then she's killed by destiny and and a
mystique then that timeline continues on
so so I guess as the Kate there's nine
timelines that have been created by more
McTaggart existence so far and then I
guess we're in the tenth see I thought
that's what he wasn't going for like I
thought he wasn't going for that but
yeah this like I've never been baffled
by x-men in my life like I have never
been confused by the x-men in my entire
life and Hickman is two issues in the
house of X and he's already baffled me
like okay
so so that's kind of know usually it's
kind of weird but huh that's kind of
wild it's mind I mean yeah what's not
really mind I mean but um that's what it
looks like where she died she just goes
back and restarts again right so it was
like she and her life ends on that she
goes back to the very beginning and goes
forward she hears it okay so here's the
thing see a lot of people will give me
[ __ ] about that right but here's here's
the important thing to keep in mind like
there's like there's the sea to me there
was never anything wrong with reaching
out and being on hey guys so like maybe
I have this wrong like somebody helped
me if I'm wrong or something like that
it'll just like like how can you become
as explained if you get [ __ ] wrong
because I'm human but uh but know if
this is this is interesting see if
that's the case if that's the case that
changes up everything then because what
it does now if there's alternate
realities out there then it gives didn't
what it does it can set more like more
macabre she already telepathically
allowed Charles Xavier to read her mind
and see all of her lives
so now it goes forward and because
here's the thing I don't think her being
reborn erases the timeline like I don't
think her being reborn like like a race
of the timeline innocent tired II like
well okay so so that's no okay cuz
here's the thing so like my thought was
we were in the 11th timeline I'm sorry
we were not we're not in a lot of
timeline because when she had 30 she was
13 years old she had the flu with a
fever whatever was and then she then
like her powers manifest and I guess she
came back just fine um I don't know it's
weird but like I mean I don't think
there's any reason to believe the
timeline will be erased right because
the timeline exists because of her
actions but her dying does not like keep
the timeline from existing she just
reincarnates and that's basically yet
but yeah she's Debbie my thought like
the only way to eliminate that timeline
will be to eradicate like would be to go
back to a point before and like she
never does anything that leads to that
timeline right it's like she never goes
to magneto she never goes to apocalypse
or any of those guys and they never
launched their attacks against humanity
but even then like you've created a
timeline with that never happen so
there's there's no way to avoid new
timeline creation I mean yeah that's
crazy
now I don't think she resets time when
she's reborn that's what I'm saying like
I don't think she researched how many
thing when she's born but I don't really
have any mom or collectibles from the
most part but you guys want to see
something cool
check this out here's something kind of
bonkers all right I don't know if you
guys will be able to see it very well
I'll try to make it you guys can see it
but there's a CGC Phoenix force the part
of the Dark Phoenix saga and then Dark
Phoenix saga so those are really cool
and then here's here's something really
badass already here's something really
badass and I want to show you guys I got
this a San Diego comic-con alright
this right here look at this giant sized
X the number one I had an autographed by
Jonathan Hickman and he made it out to
me directly so like it's like I'm never
gonna sell that thing and even I mean if
I wanted to would be worthless right
because it's made out to me directly so
it's like you know to rob from Jonathan
Hickman I was like that's badass
yeah yeah - number one is pretty badass
like I'm pretty hyped about it but huh
well it's I mean yeah I guess it kind of
is yeah the modern era of the x-men
started there so but it's yes it's
pretty sweet so what if it's explained
that she created the Days of Future past
Harlan see I don't think that's Oh see
maybe see okay because hitman could do
that that's see that's the that's the
issue see I thought Hickman was trying
to avoid alternate realities and I
thought I thought that that's possible
was he also that Days of Future past was
caused by by mystique and the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants killing
Senator Robert Kelly more McTaggart and
Professor X Y so it was their actions
that led to the death to led to the Days
of Future past storyline it wasn't
really more McTaggart it'd be different
of Days of Future past was like there
was no real indication of how it started
it just happened and then you know it
just ended in that case take me go do
something with it but at the moment
there's nothing to indicate that
that she's the cause of it so oh yes
it's bad so don't mean I'm going to I'm
gonna keep that forever okay my GoPro is
all hooked up
does she have anything to do with age of
X man I don't think so
see that's the cool SC that's the
question though because now everything
smiles up I rolls out it could just be
one of these things where Hickman's like
the only time lines more of a tiger
caused um my channels up living you
unsubscribe oh okay well you just
refresh you have to refresh a couple
times and then hit on if that's what you
wanna do but but no there's like it
could be the Hickman comes along and
just says like that's like the realities
that are there are the only realities
that that she like the ones that you
specify are the only ones that she's
created but ya know we're missing the
six timeline but I don't know hey gonna
probably come back and address that
later on right I mean it's the it's a
living tribunal effect right like like
the letting tribunal dies and at the
like near the beginning of Avengers and
New Avengers by Jonathan Hickman and
then you don't find out until near the
end how that happened but like that like
you don't find out into the end about
how that happened probably cuz I got a
house with Extron it sometimes I get
these weird finicky fans or they're like
you got a thing wrong unsub like it's
it's kind of weird to me you know I
don't have a problem with it but uh but
yeah like it's it's it's nuts see this
see this is why it's important to have
fans that like aren't as knowledgeable
if not more knowledgeable about comics
right because and you can hit them up
and just be like hey so like correct me
if I'm wrong here but it's it's it's
nuts I wasn't like I will say this like
the fact that Hickman could baffle me on
the x-men really kind of like it takes
me by surprise a little bit but also you
to figure out what I'm gonna do for
watch like I'm gonna what I'm gonna eat
where I is on the way to Puerto Rico
so that means there we go turn off turn
that off your eyes on a way to Puerto
Rico so that means I have the house to
myself until tomorrow when I leave to go
on my vacation I'm actually driving down
the what is it Pacific Coast Highway
so I need to figure out what I'm going
to make myself for lunch
yeah order Taco Bell or something like
that but you want to taste my cinnamon
nibbles Oh a little weird what sounds
good for lunch guys what should I get
for lunch yeah we had pizza last night I
don't want to cook anything because I'm
gonna be leaving so mm-hmm hot wings mmm
Chipotle I don't know food ham sandwich
Jimmy John sounds good a salad chicken
dance hamburgers dance hamburgers don't
have anything on my hamburgers over my
fridge let's see see here's a C okay
here's the problem with with having a
great woman in the house is everything
in the fridge is stuff that you have to
let cook or like you have to put things
together to make something as opposed to
just having like something quick you can
just like throw and microwave and heat
up see there's no like White Castle
sandwiches in the freezer
you know there's do a fridge tour you
got a refrigerator everyone's looking
let me show you the fridge hold on one
second okay so here's what we got in the
freezer there's some bacon in there
there's no in and out in Colorado be
nice if there was and then that's stuff
there and then there's pasta in there
and there's some mango chunks down there
bacon is always good bacon is always
good and then in the fridge there's some
beers which I'm gonna get one of those
here in a second and there's some bacon
up there I could just make like bacon
and eggs but oh yeah big in the freezer
you gotta save that stuff there's some
milk if you make myself some breakfast
I don't know and then vegetables and
cheese down there so yeah
it's uh Whataburger that would be
awesome
Wade Wilson says chimichangas check this
out look at that it lights up for some
reason people love that for some reason
like whatever I do periscopes people
would go nuts over the refrigerator that
would light up whenever I did that so um
it nature's hombre uh what's this is
that fridge but that's the thing is like
usually we're always cooking stuff so
like see you back when it was just me
when I was single that refrigerator
would be filled with monster energy
drink and like some mistake and like
that would basically be it yeah I don't
there's many snakes in them to see you
and then I have to fall now I'm out it's
like door - and Taco Bell or something I
toasted BLT with eggs I could do that
they can lettuce and tomato I think we
have let us down there and the
vegetables I'm not sure as long as
there's bacon in the fridge
uber eats hmm dude bacon eggs add some
cheese and dice up a bit of one of those
tomatoes yeah maybe but like I mean
currently cleaning up everything in the
house we're cleaning up a whole bunch
stuff in the house I don't want to have
to like do that plus I'm also I'm also
recording audio so kind of like really
tied up hmm awful flight
you gotta back into commerce because my
channel that's awesome no you can never
go wrong with bacon bacon and eggs
order some home fries and sausage and
omelette hmm mmm we need psylocke french
toast
cyclopses right okay well I'm gonna go
ahead and ounce off here guys um I'm
gonna get back to work with getting all
this stuff sorted out but thanks for the
heads up guys um I really do appreciate
its well the reason why I love having
you guys as fans because whenever I get
confused about stuff you guys can always
kind of help me clarify it a little day
right like I've got the whole history
element locked down
go from time to time I do get kind of
baffled by whatever it is the some
writers doing it's kind of the price you
pay when you go issue by issue so but I
appreciate you guys thanks for all the
helping everything and yeah I will catch
you all later peace